welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Mallette - an associate professor of
the history of art and classics her
research focuses primarily on Greek
religious art she's interested in topics
such as the divine image in Greek
religion the relationship between
artifacts and ritual the variety of
forms in Greek art from the naturalistic
to the non figural and the
historiography of the scholarship of
Greek art today we talk with her about
her new book and I congruent iqua tea
which was recently awarded the goddess
Smith International Book Prize by the
Macmillan Center the prize is awarded
annually for the best first book by a
member of the Yale faculty welcome
professor Dyckman thank you and
congratulations on the award thanks very
much
let's start with the term and I c'n ISM
since some of us may not be familiar
with what it means right
so first the word I'd like on ISM way of
the word icon and Hume there and by icon
we know what icons are there's things we
can recognize and when we say iconic in
the context of Greek art and Greek
religion we typically mean figural
things that are like in human form and
with an i could' ism we actually think
about things that are not in human form
and here in particular in relation of
representing gods okay so we're used to
seeing Aphrodite in human form goddess
of love really sexy but then I was
looking at Kate cases where she was not
represented in human form and there are
such cases and that was what drew me to
the subject so I know I couldn't miss
all that stuff that's really weird
you expect to find God's looking like
you and me or probably better than you
and me but then represented in other
ways stones or our blocks of of or
planks or just empty spaces where they
tell her here is Zeus but you can't see
the father of the God
so all these very odd things that people
don't usually talk about okay well we'll
get into the nitty-gritty oh yeah why
don't we start with an overview of your
book okay so the book basically first of
all explains the term tells us where
it's coming from with the or where this
concept is actually originating from and
I did a little bit of historiography
looking at - why and where this idea
actually emerges and that's from the
19th century and then it looks at
different ways in which we can
understand the term because it's a very
fluid and very interesting term so
that's the introduction then it looks at
the evidence what how can we actually
find how do you know that Iraq was not
just a rock but that people thought it
was Aphrodite or Zeus or Apollo so how
do we know this stuff so these are the
questions I was asking and then looking
into the evidence and some of it is
texts ancient texts like the Greek
travel writer pose Aeneas who was
travelling all over Greece and he tells
us a lot about that he was living in the
Roman in Europe but he had seen he's
like an old archaeologist in many ways
so it gives us stories we read about
other stories so the first part of the
book is about texts from ancient Greece
the second one is art my own work and
looking at just into sites and different
places in Greece where I could identify
uh-huh there is evidence there it is I
could see that and I also looked at
Greek vases with representations of
objects that are an iconic like a pillar
of Aphrodite or a pillar of Heracles so
all you have is a pillar with an
inscription but nothing else and then
they all back together in the conclusion
so it's a very it's an overview of the
question but then a lot of evidence and
then and then take it together okay so
let's talk about your research and how
you went about gathering up so I imagine
you spent a good deal of time in Greece
yes I don't complain about that he was
always locations close to the beach
I was happy no but it was really it was
first sitting in a library actually and
then I had to identify these very
different places whether it was in the
heartland of Greece and Arcadia was in
Santorini where I was looking at rock
inscriptions it was in a small island
off roads where there was an empty seat
so it's a different kind of an icon ism
or you have an empty seat of Zeus and
hecka T which is the goddess of magic so
I was really traveling in very different
places I was also looking at Greek vases
and those take you to different museums
I also went to Italy so it was a lot of
travel and not complaining it was very
exciting
very nice yeah so I am curious why the
difference between the human figure and
then the representation through the
pillar or the rock right for example why
is there a difference between the two
well represented in right right so why
are the thoughts might have innate
theories when I started working on this
was for people didn't know how to do
this they didn't they didn't know how to
draw gods so or represent them so they
just had pillars and poles and and over
time the ancient Greeks learned how to
do that but actually when I looked at
the evidence I saw that both modes
coexist so you have in certain times of
life you would have the representational
the one you can recognize the one that
everybody could see uh-huh
here is Dionysus but in other areas of
life in other contexts we will have the
non representational and these things
coexisted side-by-side and that depends
on the context only needs of the cult
because unlike in Christianity or
Judaism you know we have a lot of very
it's a wonderful world to explore many
many variations and the same God could
be shown in many different ways and they
coexisted side by side would there be
typically one way it would be shown in
life versus another way given can you
give us yeah you would have for instance
zoo
big statue in Olympia the biggest thing
ever people are just but then you will
have also an empty seat of zeus or just
an altar of zeus or a rock inscription
of zeus and that would be in different
places so in a more public cult and a
public worship you will want to have the
one that everybody can recognize
something that's more private or more
isolated or more complicated i would say
there you would have the non
representation on the an iconic and it's
true than the one we all know and
recognize the antropomorphic that's the
one we are used to but then there's
these other modes and that makes them
anthropomorphic even more interesting
this is not just because they had to do
it that way they chose to do it that way
yeah so it makes things even more
interesting how do you how do you know
by looking at something what it is
supposed to represent well that's
written or described it's a there's I
mean one way you have to do is look at
inscriptions and I was spending I spent
two weeks in Santorini in a site called
the Agora of the Gods the sort of the
marketplace over the gods and all you
had there on it rock inscriptions and
all sorts of names just of gods but
yourselves also it remains there akia
logical remains that mean suggest that
people were worshipping there but all
that we have are just rocks and
inscriptions and it's very odd but it's
an isolated area and there it seems that
the reason for that was connected to the
people the guys that were hanging out
there and they were young men on the
verge of becoming part of society so in
this kind of transitional phases of life
they were engaged and that kind of
worship very interesting did you
encounter any surprises when you were
writing the book
well traveling well finding the the seed
of Zeus was that quite an ordeal because
and where is the seed of Zeus so it's a
very small island that no one has heard
of only echo tourists that really want
to get away from everything we'll get to
this small island off Rhodes
it's called Kalki
and I thought okay I'll just go and I
will find it because there was an old
published publication from 1892 so I was
alright and I went there and it's an ISO
such a small island you couldn't even
come with a car to the island they don't
even have street names on that island
it's just you know it's like a village
in Island that is a village but gorgeous
I mean oh my god beaches that you have
to have the fishermen take you there on
a boat so it's really and I thought okay
no problem I'll just get there I'll do
one day of a hike it says it was just a
couple you know a couple meters you know
100 meters from the port and get there
and I realized there's no way in hell I
could do this by myself
haha but I was really lucky and I met
two people there who helped me along the
way and we found we they actually had a
car because we lived there okay so we
drove to the site which was the ancient
necropolis of the island which is mostly
abandoned actually and we drove there
and we started climbing and we're
climbing and I have the old photo from
the old publication and looking for the
and I couldn't find it and I couldn't
find it
but thanks to my friends we actually
eventually we found the seed of Zeus and
that was hidden from you so because one
of my friends was looking for something
even more isolated than that so and
there we found it so that was a great I
mean I had no idea it would be that
difficult to find and so it was also a
nice surprise to be able to find that
yeah sounds like a wonderful idea so how
does the work that you've done on this
book differ from some of the other
research that's out there well there
wasn't much research out there that's
the truth so you're a blazer maybe there
was a book from 1903 that really was
dedicated to the question how of gods
that are not in on figural form
there's also book that looked a from a
teen in 1988 that looked at something
called sana which are supposedly the
primitive ancient predecessors to Greek
sculpture but the kind of work I've done
which is both looking at this
particular phenomenon and looking at the
archaeological record and Greek
representations of an iconic materials
like the one you see on the basis that
hasn't been really undertaken since 1903
so obvious why do you think that is
seems like a great gig if you can get it
I thought so when I thought when I
really realized that it was like whoa
but because it's hard it's hard and it's
really against everybody's expectation
you will work walk into the Yale art
gallery you see amazing images of Greek
gods and they're so attractive and
they're so compelling and so the thought
that the Greeks that had this amazing
art figural are the the tradition that
gave us naturalism in art they would
have these weird things that just
doesn't make sense so I think that's why
people didn't even think about looking
in that direction with so much so our
people do you have people who are
naysayers who say no this is direct well
there were it's gonna be interesting how
people react to the book I think
actually so far it's been very well
received I think the idea is that
because I'm not arguing that this is a
central phenomenon I'm saying this is
there but it's basically in on the
margins and that's what makes Greek art
even more exciting you understand to
greater extent that there's a way
variety of ways in which the Greeks
represented the gods and that's really
my contribution to thinking about Greek
art so there may be some naysayers I'll
be very curious to see yeah I haven't
had so far I've had very very positive
reactions good good and what about
conclusions what are some of it so some
of the conclusions are really this idea
void I call this spectrum of iconicity
so you have different ways it's not just
iconic and iconic but a range of ways of
suggesting and God is present there's
something divine here and that actually
this idea that an iconic came before
iconic is a is a way of writing a
history so you think you when you start
thinking about your own history we say
we start from the simple and we develop
but actually
reality the two were side by side so
doing this very big survey and looking
into all the evidence really gave me an
idea between showed me how history the
way we write it and then the reality are
sort of two different things and we have
to think about that now it just crossed
my mind was there one specific instance
where you came across a symbol that said
hey I think I'm on to something
you know what gave you the idea
basically to to explore this so this is
the whole project actually it started
off when I was in grad school in a
seminar that I really didn't want to
take because let me how things work out
that I know I really didn't want to take
that class and that class was about
Cyprus and I wanted to study about
Greece but my my professor at the time
was digging in Cyprus so and he was
interested in Cyprus and I had no choice
but to go and take the class cuz it was
a very old-fashioned program so and when
my students complain I just have to
refer them to that story so I really
didn't want to take the class but I had
to but then I realized that in Cyprus
there was a lot of that kind of stuff
and I got really intrigued there was one
site where there was one stone and it
was surrounded with lots and lots of
figurines and he seems like everybody
was worshipping that's doing it's a site
on the northern part of Cyprus
it's called aya arena it's where now is
a Turkish side of Cyprus so I was really
intrigued why would you have a stone
where they knew how to represent gods
they knew how to make images but the
divine was somehow represented by a
round rock where all the worshipers were
represented by terracotta figurines and
then I started reading and it was like
of course there was such a phenomenon
and I had no idea
nobody told me so it started there
everybody thought I was crazy
and they thought it's impossible and
there's not that much in the end of the
day I had too much and I'm sure there's
more evidence I couldn't cover in the
book so it was very exciting very
interesting thank you so much for being
here with us today and sharing some of
your work thank you that's great for
more information about professor Wiseman
and her work please visit our website at
yale.edu slash macmillan report be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the Macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale
you